so it's the button
you can't help but notice that you're
sweating got any secrets you'd like to
share
no you know some thieves have a tell
like talking with your hand over your
mouth oh
or tricks
you don't have the courage or the
intelligence to have stolen anything
then why are you even talking to me i
just wanted you to know that
did i steal the fruit no was it an act
of civil disobedience that i admire yes
do i know who stole it
no stop interrogating yourself maybe you
put the fruit somewhere and forgot one
time i texted bo that i couldn't find my
phone and then he's like hey tommy what
are you texting me on and i'm like oh
yeah all right goofy face emoji
[Music]
what was that
do i like fruit yes what's my favorite
fruit
tropical be more specific
mango
now there's something about you i just
don't trust
same rules as last time no kissing no
eye contact i leave as soon as you're
done oh we're not sleeping together that
was just a negotiation tactic with glenn
oh
right
of course [__] smart
i mean if someone actually cared it
could be super hurtful but it's not
me
i'd like you to meet my new surrogate
she's ready to rock isn't that right
sandra yeah
i'm really excited
and i have no problem signing all the
paperwork so let's do it
sandra
you're gonna go with sandra
you are gonna leave your baby at the
mercy of a person whose judgment is so
bad she moved from hawaii to saint louis
yes i am and as soon as i give sandra
the shot our deal is over fine good
marcus
that was just foreplay all right we're
about to get this thing going sandra
lift your shirt marcus take off your
shirt fair warning i still have a bit of
a thanksgiving punch i'm working off all
right this is happening oh oh well you
know what else is happening
over here here we go
guys guys guys
you both know what you're doing so just
stop pretending
glenn you obviously don't want to use
sandra of course i don't want to use
sandra who would want to use sandra you
think i want to have sex with marcus he
starts every time by saying i'm not
really sure what i'm doing down there oh
sorry for being honest well both of you
clearly want this to just get over it
fine with me
all right
so
i guess we should
go back to work are you
hitting on me i honestly i can't tell
anymore this is a waste of time look
dina i just think that you're holding in
a lot of pent-up emotion and that it's
good to talk about these things i
learned that in couples therapy oh and
that worked out great for you didn't it
tina that didn't work out for them
though actually they're getting a
divorce
anybody want any
meat nobody
really nobody nobody wants meat
i'll take some aren't you vegan oh yeah
just for like 20 years but when i see
meat that looks that delicious
i have to make an exception no tina you
don't have to eat that oh
i
guess this is what he used to stand on
they just took off the little foot
i'm going to eat a bird now
i'm gonna
wow
but is it worth it for that taste
[Laughter]
yum jonah i don't feel you were uh fair
to me wait a minute this sounds nothing
like kelly it's more like
hi everybody i'm kelly no wait no wait
hold on let's do this nice and accurate
how about it okay dina it's not about
doing impressions hey it's me kelly boy
it sure is windy out today whoa
that seems unnecessary jonah you told me
you love me and then you dumped me so
you could have sex with that pregnant
[__] hey these are kelly's words not
mine you know this right here right now
this is my greatest trauma glenn let's
just wrap this up yeah i'm out of here
no dina look listen i get it you want me
to suddenly get in touch with some deep
dark emotions but guess what i don't
have time to whine about my issues and
frankly i am sick of listening to all
you people whine about yours get off me
move brett
i wanted to bring dina up here so we
could discuss this morning's incident
listen
i don't need an atta boy just for doing
my job okay but i do think it's positive
that this can open a conversation about
self-defense and how each of us need to
take action what i'm saying is don't do
what dina did
i'm sorry what he said don't be like you
deena took it upon herself to physically
confront the thief and while it worked
out okay this time it could have turned
into serious injury or death or god
forbid a lawsuit
i'm obviously joking uh lawsuit would
not be as bad as death the point is we
have a policy for this so if you see
something suspicious report it don't try
to handle it yourself yeah we all know
what the policy is but what was i
supposed to do just stand there and make
brown like jonah
what did jonah do well i i didn't
actually do anything exactly he just sat
there and watched a guy rob the store
thank you that is what you should all do
in the future thank you jonah for
actually following protocol oh well
yeah i mean and you know you guys came
up with a policy i just knew it and and
followed it it's appreciated oh my god
just sleep with him already what okay
what if someone steals a baby what then
do you want me to just sit there and
watch someone take a baby what if the
baby is wearing a bomb then wouldn't you
want him to steal it i'm trying to
picture a scenario in which somebody
plays oh what if it's baby hitler
a very good question tough is it i think
you gotta kill that baby hitler yeah
well how would you know that that baby
was gonna grow up to be hitler what if
that baby was gonna grow up to be the
exact opposite of hitler churchill no
lance bass interesting
oprah yeah oprah
you got to save that baby dina beats you
up or everyone gets to see you hit a
woman it's not gonna come to that
bullies just need to be confronted there
officially off cloud9 property now we're
just a couple of civilians
so show me what you got look dina i'm
not i'm not fighting you this is why
because i'm a woman because if you were
really a feminist you'd punch me in the
face what is that
okay what are you what are you doing i'm
not gonna do that this has been a long
time coming
what
since this morning
wait guys
stop
this is crazy thank you
now we're good garrett you don't need to
you can turn it off
i don't want to do this fight me no come
on [__] me stop dina get off dana get
off
what the hell is that
nothing what's wrong man are you okay
yeah yeah i'm good i'm good i just just
give me a a minute did you just get an
erection what no
hey so random i was going through some
old security footage with luanne yeah
and you remember how we used to have
those security cameras in the break room
well we came across the time you let all
my birds escape
uh
yeah
remember that remember it was
valentine's day remember i was blaming
myself for it and then when i was at my
lowest you had sex with me knowing that
hours before you were the one that let
them out and you knew the entire time
and yet you said nothing remember that
that was so funny
dina i'm so so sorry hey come on don't
even worry about it i forgive you when
you think about it this whole thing is
just funny
hey come with me i want to show you
something
they went up so fast it's like they
wanted to burn
what's that sound
is that air escaping from the sneakers
it almost sounds like they're
screaming will never forgive you
ever
you